our eye on earth coverage continues with
a new warning about climate change
that potentially dire consequences the
world a meteorological organization says
there's a 40
chance that temperatures will
temporarily hit a disturbing threshold
in the next five years
that's 1.5 degrees celsius above
pre-industrial levels
scientists say breaching that marker
would dramatically increase the risk of
extreme floods
drought and wildfires the warning comes
as
three big oil companies chevron
exxonmobil
and shell all face setbacks this week
over their role in climate change we're
joined now by cbs news
meteorologist and climate specialist
jeff berardelli jeff
good morning how dire is this actually
expected to get
so yeah in the next five years it is
somewhat likely that we'll hit 1.5
degrees celsius briefly
temporarily that's 2.7 degrees
fahrenheit of warming since
pre-industrial times it's likely to
happen during an el nino year that's
when it's really warm in the pacific so
natural variations on top of climate
change
then it will go back down but you know
this is really just a sign
that humanity isn't doing very well
in managing our global greenhouse
emissions and
at 1.5 degrees celsius it's not like
we're going to fall off a cliff
where things all of a sudden are going
to get catastrophic but things will
progressively get worse at a much
faster pace the intensity of these
extreme weather events will pick up
we'll see compounded events heat waves
on top of sea level rise
on top of large hurricanes and impactful
hurricanes
and so things will just get worse and
worse if we breach that and the bottom
line is by 2030
2035 unless we really reign in our
emissions very quickly
we are likely to get to 1.5 degrees and
continue to increase our warming
close to 2 degrees and again we have to
do something very quickly about it
or we're inevitably heading in that
direction you say that jeff says this is
a symbolic marker
why
yeah because i mean humans chose it
right we chose 1.5 we chose 2 degrees
so again it's not a tipping point it's
not like we're going to fall off a cliff
it's just that things will get
progressively worse and worse at a
faster clip
as we head towards that we'll see bigger
hurricanes we'll see worse floods
we'll see worse wildfires and we're
probably setting ourselves up for a
pretty bad wildfire season in the west
this year
all right jeff baradelli thanks so much